[Musik]
was bisher geschah morgen
was ist mit ihnen haben sich auf dem Weg
nach Sylt Verfahren
und jetzt werden hierfür ein Gast
Terminal Millionen Liter an Chlor ins
Meer geleitet ich meine Frage ist
einfach nur wollen sie ein Taschentuch
haben
es ist denn überhaupt ein richtiger
Eröffnung eines gasterminals wenn Gerd
Schröder nicht dabei ist
das finde ich eine lustige Frage
werden wir es denn auch irgendwann mal
schaffen dass auch Windräder so schnell
gebaut werden können das wäre das
Projekt ja
also für diesen Winter haben wir schon
mal genug Gas aber was ist mit dem
Winter in 20 Jahren Stichwort
erneuerbare gute Frage zum Glück kenne
ich Professor quaschnik von der
Universität Berlin er ist sehr sehr
schlau warte mal du kennst jemanden von
der Uni
[Musik]
Herr Professor quatschnecken sie haben
ja die Energiepolitik der letzten
Jahrzehnte ein Totalversagen genannt
wurde dann auch irgendwas richtig
gemacht so
naja wir haben relativ früh in die
Solarenergie investiert das war also
hier Deutschland mal groß gemacht haben
als es dann geklappt hat und die solange
die billig war haben sie halt den
Chinesen gegeben das war jetzt auch
nicht so richtig clever aber
genau
richtig verkackt oder also
wirtschaftspolitisch gesehen war das
nicht sonderlich clever wir merken das
ja gerade also
sagt der Professor ja und so sagt der
studienabrechnung das Ziel der Ampel 80%
des Stroms bis 2030 aus erneuerbaren
Energien klingt erstmal gut aber alleine
im Bereich Solarenergie bräuchten wir
dafür 100 Fußballfelder foto-teig und
zwar nicht pro Jahr sondern pro Tag wenn
Sie jetzt von dem Fernseher sitzen und
sich fragen wie sollen wir das denn
schaffen der hätte man ja viel früher
anfangen müssen weil Windrädern müssen
wir unsere Ausbau Geschwindigkeit
verdreifachen und allein Bayern das 2040
klimaneutral sein will bräuchte zudem
pro Woche ein neues Umspannwerk sechs
Schiff Container mit batteriespeichern
und fünf Container mit
elektrolyseanlagen wie gesagt pro Woche
da ist es wahrscheinlich ja das Olaf
Scholz noch mal Kanzler wird
okay gut
aber selbst wenn wir das alles auf dem
Papier schaffen fehlt allein bis 2025
für den Ausbau schon 180.000
Arbeitskräfte und ob wir die
Energiewende mit ungebildeten
ungelernten und unqualifizierten
Hilfsarbeitern wirklich hinkriegen das
könnte echt sein dass wir im
Fachkräftemangel scheitern auch ja also
wenn wir die Energiewende wirklich
durchziehen so dass wir klimaneutral
werden in der Zeit die das Pariser
Klimaschutzabkommen vorkommt dann
brauchen wir mal mindestens eine halbe
Million oder noch mehr Menschen die dann
plötzlich in dem energiewendebereich
Arbeiten glauben Sie denn dass man auch
Problemfälle die am Arbeitsmarkt nicht
mehr vermittelbar sind noch umschulen
könnte
also so ein Solarmodul halten und
anschrauben ist jetzt nicht so
kompliziert also
arbeiterstrich Berlin Mitte hier beginnt
also mein neues Leben Facharbeiter in
ein paar Tagen das ist genau mein Ding
so bin ich schließlich auch zur heute
show gekommen Kinder ist das aufregend
das ist der Bus der fährt uns gleich in
die endpal-akademie wo wir alle
ausgebildet werden zu
solaranlagenmonteur also alles
Quereinsteiger hier wir sind sehr
aufgeregt hallo der Bus fährt aber schon
mit Solarenergie ne natürlich wirklich
nicht ich habe ein gutes Gefühl und los
geht's
oh die sind echt alle gut drauf hier und
auch voll nett ich bin Wolfgang können
mich gerne duzen
15 Minuten Busfahrt Gott sei Dank hatte
ich für das leibliche Wohl vorgesorgt
wer hat arbeitet der muss seinen Körper
unter Strom halten Eier wir brauchen
Eier denn Fachkräftemangel das kann doch
nicht so weitergehen drei Kilo schwerer
endlich angekommen irgendwo in
Brandenburg und auch hier treffe ich
wieder auf Politiker manchmal ist das
schon beängstigend denn sie sind überall
und machen alles mit Herr Kellner das
finde ich ein starkes Signal dass sie
sich umschulen lassen zum
solaranlagenmonteur jetzt hier heute
dass wir nicht toll mir wurde gesagt sie
lassen sich um schon und ich dachte wir
machen das beide ja alle alle wieso
haben wir denn jetzt diesen
Fachkräftemangel wir waren mal
Weltmarktführer und jetzt auf einmal
stehen wir so da wie konnte das
passieren ja es ist einerseits der
demokratische Wandel das ist
andererseits in den letzten Jahren eine
mangelnde Fachkräfte Einwanderung und es
ist drittens glaube ich auch eine
unterschiedliche Frage dass wir dass wir
sagen Mensch man kann genauso gut man
muss nicht nur studieren man kann
genauso gut im Handwerksbereich goldenen
Boden finden
doch ganz schön kompliziert alles ob das
das nächste Studium wird dass ich
abbreche andererseits braucht man hier
jeden Mann denn der Markt ist wie
leergefegt der Markt ist wie leergefegt
gerade bei wenn man sich Elektriker
anschaut wir kriegen noch Elektriker
aber leider nicht genug wir haben Koch
der bei uns super gut und schnell
Anlagen baut die Kunden sind super happy
also wir geben wirklich auch den
Kollegen Kollegen eine Chance bei uns
das heißt sie sind schuld dass ich im
Restaurant jetzt immer so lange aufs
Essen warten muss vielen Dank
scheint so zu sein es tut mir leid so
der Kollege hier der wollte unbedingt
mit in die Produktion das Reiten sie
mich da jetzt hier rein das haben sie
doch vorhin eben gesagt dass habe ich ja
jetzt habe ich ja gut okay ja ich wollte
unbedingt auch mitmachen wie machen wir
uns ein bisher so was würden Sie sagen
so also ihr macht ja im Moment noch nix
ja ja
[Musik]
perfekt ist aber anders oder Kevin jetzt
mal ehrlich bei ihnen sah das ein
bisschen ich will sie jetzt nicht
schlecht machen
Herr Kellner gucken Sie ruhig mal damit
es beim nächsten Mal besser machen
überhaupt kein überhaupt kein Druck ja
bei ihnen war eben ja ja
dann ist verkehrt ja lachen sie da die
ganze Zeit eigentlich
Empathie das ist wirklich zu Ende machen
so Schnitt ab jetzt schneiden wir das
davor wird eh nicht reingeschnitten ne
so macht man es nicht
was ich feststelle wir können fast jeden
kleinen Schläger zum dachmotor machen
bei ihm müssen wir glaube ich noch mal
gucken ob sie vielleicht der erste sind
bei dem was nicht schaffen ich bin ein
Unikat auf jeden Fall
meine Männer
china hat ein weltweiten Marktanteil von
75 Prozent was Solarmodule angeht also
wir sind ja eigentlich abhängig von
China versuchen uns gerade unabhängig zu
machen von Russland was ist denn wenn
jetzt China Taiwan überfällt ganz doof
gesagt Energiewende am Arsch oder
Energie wenn am Arsch aber dann haben
wir auch so Probleme ich meine dann
kriegen wir ja auch wir kriegen ja nicht
mehr Zahnräder oder irgendwelche Chips
also dann liegt Deutschland sowieso dann
nieder würde überhaupt in Deutschland
noch
mehr Toiletten dann nicht mehr Toiletten
und das ist natürlich das Schlimmste das
ist für die nächste Krise natürlich eine
Herausforderung aber es wäre dann
wirklich ein riesen Problem oder das
Toilettenpapier
also wir sind ja total abhängig wir
stecken in der Scheiße das ist genial
der Antrag für eine Windkraftanlage
umfasst 50 gefüllte Aktenordner was zur
Hölle steht da drin das wird mich
wirklich mal interessieren ich weiß es
nicht ich habe so diese Anträge gesehen
eine Munitionsfabrik zu bauen ist
wahrscheinlich eh nicht kompliziert und
es geht halt einfach wenn ich was nicht
will wird es in Deutschland nicht
verboten es wird dann einfach
kompliziert gemacht das ist genial
eigentlich oder
vergessen Sie die Pyramiden von Gizeh
und den Koloss von Rhodos hier ein
wirkliches Weltwunder die Windräder von
Baden-Württemberg um sie ranken sich
Legenden doch es gibt sie wirklich ich
treffe ihren Erschaffer an einem
mythischen Ort voller Geheimnisse sie
betreiben Windräder in Deutschland wir
können ja offen sprechen haben sie einen
kleinen Fetisch für Formulare
wir betreiben seit 99 Windräder in
Süddeutschland inzwischen sind wir halbe
Biologen und wir haben natürlich wir
sind Papiertiger geworden sie sehen hier
das ist ein windkraftantrag von unserem
Windpark hier vor Ort aber das wäre ja
jetzt so wahrscheinlich so 100 200
Windräder sein oder die genau sie können
sich vorstellen in diesen vielen Ordner
ist unzähliges Papier von unzähligen
Dienstleistern Gutachtern für jeweils
eine Windkraftanlage ja korrekt genau so
wenn man jetzt hier zurückschauen
wir haben hier eine Genehmigung und
einen Antrag es war damals ein kleiner
Leitzordner das ist von 1999 hier die
Genehmigung dazu fünf sechs Seiten das
ist jetzt alles heute hier das was hier
liegt ja genau so jetzt geht es aber
noch weiter sie brauchen hier für die
Träger öffentliche wie lange das ganze
10-12 15 Fach je nach Anforderung der
Behörde damit 5 15-fach ja genau gut
jedes Projekt beinhaltet die eigenen
Auflagen und die eigenen
Herausforderungen hier im Windpark haben
wir sehr starken Fokus gehabt auf die
Haselmaus und auf die Gelbbauchunke
wobei ich die gelb warum
total putzige unten auf die ist wirklich
schön die Gelbbauchunke auch bergunkel
genannt gehört innerhalb der Klasse
amphibienlichen Familie bombinatoridee
der kleine spitzwarze froschlurch an
einer unscheinbar gefärbte Oberseite
während die Bauchseite eine Leuchten
gelbe wandfärbung aufweist der kleine
Rauke kommt häufig in Europa vor und
bevorzugt Pfützen rund um noch nicht
genehmigte Windräder erstaunlich auf
seine Fortpflanzung oh nee
wir haben hier sehr viele
gelbbauchunkentümpel geschaffen geht
nach unten Tümpel korrekt über 20 Stück
wir haben hier normale Pfützen wie sie
hier eine sehen die haben jetzt im
Sommer jeden Tag gegossen weil wir hier
auch das steht dann in den Ordner drin
dass sie als Auflage jeden Tag im Sommer
Pfützen gießen müssen also die gelbe
auch ungemaßnahme müssen erhalten werden
korrekt das ist beispielsweise eine der
Auflagen die hier die in der Genehmigung
drin stehen und dann stehen sie hier im
Sommer mit der Gießkanne und gießen die
Pfützen nicht nur ich auch Mitarbeiter
korrekt genau
hassen sie ihren Job nein Gottes Willen
kommen sie wir gehen die gelb auch schön
und wie oft macht man das dann so als im
Hochsommer wenn es richtig warm ist
jeden Tag ansonsten reicht es eigentlich
zwei zweimal die Woche ungefähr okay
toll was man so machen muss um so einen
Windrad zu betreiben und den gelbe auch
umgeht bei uns gut schön
[Musik]
sieht ja schon beeindruckend aus hier
absolut ich bin auch immer wieder gerne
hier ja dann vielen Dank für alles und
ich habe mal eine kleine Überraschung
für sie vorbereitet als Dankeschön kommt
rein
[Musik]
einfach hier hin
das sind 55 frische Aktenordner für ihr
neues Windrad vielen Dank nur bisschen
ein zwei Jahren bis wir soweit sind
glaube ich es wird gar nicht mehr
reichen es würde jedes Jahr mehr
Bürokratie aber ich bedanke mich
vielmals also das heißt ich soll noch
mal welche nachholen gerne ich sagte wie
viel bringe ich dann vorbei danke schön
bestelltigung der Nichtigkeit ist
Durchschrift Exemplars Essen
gültigkeitsfilm von der bezugsbehörde
stammt zum Beruf der Vorlage beim
zuständige teilungsamt
heizen E-Autos und Co unser Strombedarf
wird Demenz steigen und dafür brauchen
wir den entsprechenden Netze leider ist
unser Stromnetz weitgehend auf dem Stand
von
1990 und ich meine das ist so lange her
da hatte Olaf Scholz noch Haare und dann
funktionierendes Gedächtnis dabei wurden
schon 2004 7500 km in großen
Stromtrassen geplant fertig sind 19
Jahre später nicht mal ein Zehntel die
stromautobahn südlink von Norden in den
Süden sollte z.B letztes Jahr fertig
sein jetzt gibt es zwei Möglichkeiten
entweder ist südlink die erste komplett
unsichtbare Stromleitung der Welt oder
es wurden bisher sage und schreibe 0,0 m
dieser Trasse gebaut ja entscheiden Sie
selbst was richtig ist kleiner Typ es
ist nicht das mit dem unsichtbar und
weil das mit dem Netzausbau solarm ist
haben wir allein im ersten Halbjahr 2022
4% unseres Ökostroms umsonst produziert
und ungenutzt weggeworfen obwohl was
heißt umsonst denn wenn Ihr Strom wegen
netzengpässen nicht eingespeist werden
kann haben die Betreiber natürlich
Anspruch auf Entschädigungszahlungen
allein 2021 blächten die Verbraucher
800 7 Millionen Euro für ungenutzten
Strom könnte man diesen Strom den nicht
einfach in Pumpspeicherkraftwerken
zwischenspeichern keine Sorge das hat
der Staat doch längst geregelt denn
hierzulande muss man als Betreiber
Netzentgelt zahlen wenn der Strom in den
Speicher hineinfließt und noch mal wenn
er wieder rausfließt aber lohnt sich das
denn aus unternehmerischer Sicht
nein so jetzt schaue ich mir mal ein
Verteilnetzbetreiber an da er
systemrelevant ist befindet er sich an
einem geheimen Ort und deswegen werde
ich abgeholt schöner Service
[Musik]
ich bin ja jetzt hier an einem geheimen
Ort wir dürfen tatsächlich verraten wo
wir sind können sie ungefähr sagen wo
wir uns befinden ja wir sind jetzt hier
bei der midnetz
nur ganz kurz da ne ja genau wir sind
jetzt hier bei der mitnetz größten
Stromnetzbetreiber aus Deutschlands und
ja freuen uns ein bisschen was über die
Energiewende heute berichten zu dürfen
kann ich die Tüte jetzt abnehmen
eigentlich jetzt dürfen sie abnehmen
hi hallo
sieht ja das sieht ein bisschen aus wie
auf der Enterprise oder was genau
passiert denn da jetzt an diesen ganzen
Monitoren und in diesem Werk hier ja
grundsätzlich ist ja so dass der
Übertragungsnetzbetreiber in dem Fall
die 50 Herz hier vorgelagert und den
Strom antransportiert und wir als
Verteilnetzbetreiber sind sozusagen die
Landstraße die stromautobahn die dann
bis zum Endkunden gehen das heißt also
wir nehmen ja in Deutschland über 90%
des erneuerbaren Stroms auf in unsere
Verteilnetze und verteilen ihn Speisen
ihn zurück dann können wir ja mal
rübergehen ja
[Musik]
spannend also umspannend umspannen ja
was wir jetzt hier sehen also mir ist es
völlig klar was hier passiert klar
logisch erklären sich den Zuschauer noch
mal vielleicht haben die es nicht
verstanden was wir jetzt hier sehen
ja ich glaube wir haben heute das
Paradebeispiel für diesen regnerischen
Wintertag und heute haben wir halt
lediglich zehn Megawatt an PV
Einspeisung und 14 Megawatt an
Windeinspeisung und das bedeutet das für
ja klar sich heute den Fall haben dass
wir unsere konventionellen Kraftwerke
brauchen und den Strom aus diesen
Kraftwerken um unser Netz zu
stabilisieren also sie haben das sehr
schön erklärt aber natürlich nicht so
richtig gut ich mache das noch mal das
ist klar wird also wir haben ja hier die
Kupplung ab die ist ja Q 0 und wir sehen
dass das ja 03 ist und das geht ja
direkt über den B-Block B rüber zu ma 4
nee und wenn das runter geht haben wir
die ul1 die ist 8,9 und bei der 8,9 da
müssen wir ansetzen müssen zur notbe 23
die nostrad 23 sind dieses ganze Konzept
auch dass wir hier haben dass wir zur
MVA rüber zur distanznetz diffus aus und
dann sind wir hier in Sachsen-Anhalt
direkt bei der klammlau mal und haben
diese Blindleistung die wir hier auch
sehen
in diesem Schaubild wer so einfach
gewesen schade dass das nicht möglich
war wir haben es versucht sie haben es
versucht ist ja nicht schlimm dafür bin
ich ja da
hier ist ja auch noch so ein Knöpfchen
Schatz ich habe der Fernseher ist kaputt
also für mich so umgucke Flächen gibt es
ja genug aber dann braucht man doch
wahrscheinlich auch viele neue Leitungen
für die Erneuerbaren oder ja nicht nur
einige sondern richtig viele über 1500
km Freileitung okay und wie viel wurden
im letzten Jahr gebaut von den 1500 na
ja null null null
gut wir sind wenigstens nicht im Minus
ne
nach dem Lutz im verteilernetzwerk für
einen deutschlandweiten Blackout gesorgt
hatte mussten wir zu Fuß weiter reisen
vielen Dank noch mal stell dich nicht so
an das war nur von Sachsen bis ins
Allgäu und wir sind doch ein Team
[Musik]
mal was anderes wer hätte eigentlich
gedacht dass das Silicon Valley der
Energiewende in Bayern liegt ich sag nur
drei Namen Steve Jobs Bill Gates und
Günter mögele Herr Müller sie sind
zweiter Bürgermeister von willpoldsried
einem energieautarken Ort in Bayern was
stimmt mit ihnen nicht
stimmt bei mir ähm wir haben halt sehr
früh angefangen darüber nachzudenken
muss wo die Reise hingeht wie ist es
dazu gekommen dass sie jetzt hier
Energie unabhängig sind wir haben vor 30
Jahren einen Beschluss gefasst nicht ans
Erdgasnetz anzuschließen gute Idee ja er
hat sich jetzt rausgestellt dass der
Beschluss gar nicht so ganz dumm war wir
haben damals
Erdgas das kann es nicht sein begibt
sich in eine Abhängigkeit war damals
schon klar wie viel Strom produzieren
sie denn hier im Ort ja so circa das
Achtfache wie der Ort braucht das
Achtfache gut ja achtmal so viele Menge
das ist ja super auch für den Rest von
Deutschland weil dann geht der Strom ja
der überschüssige direkt nach ganz
Deutschland Stopp mal ganz kurz ganz
kurz Fabian muss nicht die doofsten
Fragen der Welt stellen
ja das ist ja klar dass der Rest vom
Strom nach Deutschland
Prinzip Leipziger Strombörse der der
meisten zahlt der bekommt in der Kraft
den
und das ist die Schweizer Zeit
also es läuft alles eigentlich ganz gut
in Deutschland ja
läuft super
Bayern setzt ja sonst sehr gerne auf
solarenergien Markus Söder lobt sich ja
immer Bayern ist Sonnenland ne jetzt
sehe ich hier auf ihren Solaranlagen da
liegt sowas weißes drauf können Sie
Markus oder mal erklären was das ist ich
glaube das ist Schnee drauf liegt
interessant ja in Bayern gibt es halt
öfters und wenn das so ab 10 cm wie hier
ist dann produzieren die natürlich
nichts mehr und ich finde das echt ein
schönes Bild weil man sieht hier ne da
liegt überall Schnee drauf und im
Hintergrund das Windrad das ist schön
dreht stimmt das denn das Windräder auf
doppelt so viele Volllaststunden kommen
wie Solar Energie ja auf jeden Fall also
es ist Solaranlage bei uns wenn es gut
geht kommt immer auf 1000 Stunden
Verlass und mindestens 2000 damals sogar
bis 2500 in unserer Tage wie viele von
diesen Windräder brauchen sie jetzt um
den Ort zu versorgen
eins nehmen wir das anschaut die
neuesten die haben drei Megawatt
Leistung maximal und das erzeugt mehr
Strom als der ganze Ort braucht ein
einziges und dieses ganze Solarfeld
gerade meinen Bruchteil davon und jetzt
natürlich mit der garnicht
also Lutz wenn die jetzt hier sogar das
Bier klimaneutral Brauen würden dann
könnte ich mir echt vorstellen hier zu
bleiben ja komm jetzt übertreib mal
nicht du Fantast wusstet ihr eigentlich
dass auch unser Bier klimaneutral ist
wirklich ernsthaft ja natürlich das ist
zu 100 % als Wasser und natürlich auch
100 % der Strom gebraucht okay jetzt bin
ich endgültig überzeugt wir bleiben hier
würde ich auch oder
unser Motto ist saufen gegen Putin
vielleicht
Fabian Lutz ich bin hier hier folgt
meiner Stimme ich habe dich jetzt
übertreiben die das aber mit dem
Energiesparen oder sogar in der endcard
ja klickt HIER wenn ihr abonnieren wollt
oder hier für weitere Videos
wo geht es denn jetzt hier raus ich
glaube da lang ah mein Fuß